hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD tutorial and which I plan on giving
you a little walkthrough of the windows
7 calculator and this is now actually
available for people it's been available
but this is available for people who are
using Windows Vista 32-bit and 64-bit so
you can use this on two platforms
Windows Vista and Windows 7 but I really
like the windows 7 calculator so I
figured I'd show this to you guys and
this you know the link in the
description which I'll provide is right
here it's going to give you guys a
little description of it and I'm
actually going to show you guys the
calculator itself since I have it
downloaded and installed I click on the
shortcut and I'm just going to compare
this to the built-in Windows Vista
calculator so I have them both pulled up
right here on the left as you can see
here is the windows 7 calculator and on
the right is the windows vista
calculator and number one first thing
you'll notice is that it's a lot it's a
little different color and it's going to
look a lot sleeker when you change
between modes so here's the cool thing
about the windows 7 calculator there are
modes you just go ahead and hit that
mode button it's automatically in
standard and you can use these keyboard
shortcuts to switch to scientific to
programmer and to statistics mode and
watch the animation as it switches so
just does this quick little animation
and it looks a lot smoother obviously
when you're not screen recording but
there is there are several modes of this
calculator now the window is just a
calculator there's really not that much
to look at you can copy and paste values
and you can view in two different modes
standard and scientific and it actually
opens what looks like a new window when
you go back to standard in scientific so
that's a little bit different than the
windows 7 calculator and then there's a
Help button you know in both calculators
you can choose about calculator and go
to you know further help and support
topics but when I you know when you're
when you're going through operations in
the Windows 7 calculator there's also a
history so if I go 9 x 9 all right
8 divided by 6
6/8 you can see up top there's a history
of the three operations I just did and I
can go up and up and go back to those
operations which is not available in the
built-in Windows Vista calculator so
this is going to be built into Windows 7
which is really cool I really can't wait
to install the full version of Windows 7
on this laptop but I really like the
fact that there is history and that
there is smooth transition between the
modes of the calculator and it just has
an overall cool look to it so if you
guys are you know interested in
downloading and installing and actually
using this calculator you can go ahead
and throw a shortcut in your dock like I
did and that is basically it guys so um
thanks for watching this little short
little H tutorial if you need any help
with installing and just go ahead and
leave a comment message and that is
basically it so uh thanks for watching
enjoy the windows 7 calculator and I'll
catch you guys in the next video peace